if you think this cockatoo is like any
other think again meat snowball who
became an internet sensation in 2007
thanks to this head bopping and toe
tapping performance more than a decade
later and he's still having fun
[Music]
scientists wanted to know why so they
spent the last ten years at study his
moves the key here is that the fact that
he's displaying new movements suggests
to us that it's not just recycling
moving patterns that are due to look
emotion or mating that he's actually
using the higher parts of his brain to
create new movement patterns in time
with music so this is really something
that we find having hallmarks of dance
researchers were struck by snowballs
creativity because he was able to
choreograph as many as 14 different
moves so what is behind snowballs
ability to dance so well how is it
possible for a feathered bird to possess
such rhythm well we're gonna find out
Jordan there is also a cockatoo he's 6
years old and he's been on this farm for
just over a week we're gonna play one or
two classics to see if he reacts
in rocking side to side it's big to say
he's the baddest inspector so just how
unusual is it to see a dancing cockatoo
it's quite common for a lot of birds to
do all sorts of different sort of dance
moves when a display with another
setting up territory or they're
attracting to a mate so for want to do
it to music doesn't really come as a
huge surprise because some birds will
start a song and start a set of display
in actions in line with one sequence of
the song and then as I switched to
another they'll change to another table
display move as well so maybe inherit
already within that species snowball is
the only bird that known to be
scientifically analyzed in this way but
researchers say the study wasn't just
fun it was invaluable in helping to
discover more about the human brain
no Philips Sky News